now I'll give you a slightly more
complicated choice between two payment
options both of them are good because in
either case you're getting money so
choice one so choice one choice choice
choice one today I will give you let's
say I will give you $100 choice oh then
I'll Circle the payment when you get it
in magenta so today you get $100 choice
two and I'll try to write this choice a
little bit neater choice - is that not
in one year but in two years so let's
say this is year one year one and now
this is year two actually I want to give
you three choices that that'll that'll
really hopefully hit things home it's
actually let me scoot this choice - over
to the left if I scoot it over to the
left look back at the green so now I'm
back in business a choice - choice - I
am willing to give you let's say oh I
don't know one hundred and ten dollars
in two years so not in one year in two
years I'm going to give you one hundred
and ten dollars and so I'll circle in
magenta when you actually get your
payment and then choice 3 and choice
three is going to be fascinating choice
three I've been in a slightly different
shade of green choice three I am going
to pay you I'm making this up on the fly
as I go I'm going to pay you $20 today
$20 today I'm going to pay you $50 in
one year
so let's see it's 70 let me make this so
it's close and then I'm going to pay you
I don't know 35 dollars in year three
thirty-five dollars in year three so all
of these are payments I want to
differentiate between the actual dollar
payments and the present values and just
for the sake of simplicity let's assume
that I am guaranteed I am the safest
person available if the world exists if
the Sun does not supernova I will be
paying you this amount of money so I'm
as I am as risk free as the federal
government and I had a a post on the on
the previous present value where someone
talked about well is the federal
government really that safe and and this
is the point the federal government when
it borrows from you $100 let's say it
borrows $100 and it promises to pay it
in a year it'll give you that hundred
dollars the risk is what is that hundred
dollars worth because they might inflate
the currency to death anyway I won't go
into that right now let's just go back
to this present this present value
problem and actually sometimes
governments do default on debt but you
know that the US government has never
defaulted its inflated its currency so
that's that's kind of a roundabout way
of defaulting but it's never actually
said I will not pay you because if that
happened our entire financial system
would blow up and we would all be living
off the land again anyway back to this
problem enough commentary from Sal so
let's just compare twice 1 and choice 2
again and once again let's say that
risk-free I could put money I could lend
it to the federal government at 5% and
it doesn't matter over what risk free
rate risk-free rate is 5 percent and for
the sake of simplicity in the next video
I'll I will make that assumption less
simple but for the sake of simplicity
the government will pay you 5% whether
you give them the money for 1 year
whether you give them the money for 2
years or whether you give them the money
for 3 years
right so if I had $100 what would that
be worth in one year we figured that out
already it's 100 times 1.05 so that's
105 dollars and then what if you got
another 5% so the government is giving
you 5% per year it would be 105 times
1.05 and what is that so I have 105
times 1.05 so is equal one hundred and
ten dollars and twenty five cents one
hundred and ten dollars and twenty five
cents so that is a value in two years so
immediately without even doing any
present value we see that you'll
actually be better off in two years if
you were to take the money now and just
lend it to the government because the
government risk-free will give you $110
25 cents in two years while I'm only
willing to give you 110 dollars so let's
that's all fair and good but the whole
topic what we're trying to solve is
present value so let's take everything
in today's money and to take this $110
and say what is that worth today we can
just discount it backwards by the same
method right so $110 in two years
what is its one-year value well you take
one hundred and ten dollars and you
divide it by 1.05 right you're just
doing the reverse and then you get some
number here well that number you get is
110 divided by 1.05 and then to get its
present value its value today you divide
that by 1.05 again so you get 110 divide
it if I were to divide by 1.05 again
what do I get I divided by 1.05 and then
I divided by 1.05 again I'm dividing by
1.05 squared and what is that equal and
I'm writing this on purpose because I
want to get you used to this notation
because this is what all of our present
values in our discounted cash flow this
this type of dividing by
plus the discount rate ^ however many
years out this is this is what all of
that's based on and that's all we're
doing though we're just dividing by 1.05
twice because we're two years out so
let's do that
okay just well let's just do that 110
divided by 1.05 squared is equal to
ninety-nine point seven seven dollars so
it equals let me do that in a different
color it equals ninety-nine point seven
seven so once again we have verified by
taking the present value of $110 in two
years two today that today it's present
value if we assume a five percent
discount rate and this discount rate
this is this is where all of the all of
the the fudge factor occurs in finance
you can you can tweak that discount rate
and make a few assumptions in discount
rate and pretty much assume anything but
right now first for simplification we're
assuming a risk-free discount rate but
when you present value it based on that
you get ninety nine dollar seventy seven
cents you say wow yeah this really isn't
as good as this 99 I would rather have
$100 today than ninety nine dollars and
seventy seven cents today now this is
interesting choice number three how do
we look at this well what we do is we
present value each of the payments right
so the present value of twenty dollars a
day well that's just twenty dollars
what's the present value of fifty
dollars in one year
well the present value of that is going
to be so plus fifty dollars divided by
1.05 right that's the present value of
the fifty dollars because one year out
and then I want the present value of the
thirty-five dollars so that's plus
thirty five dollars divided by what it's
two years out right so you have to
discount it twice divided by 1.05
squared just like we did here so let's
figure out what that present value is
notice I'm just adding up the present
values of each of those payments get out
my virtual ti-85 and see so the present
value of the twenty dollar payment is
twenty dollars
plus the present value of the $50
payment well that's just fifty divided
by 1.05 plus the present value of our
$35 payment 35 divided by and it's two
years out so we discount by our discount
rate twice so it's divided by 1.05
squared and then that is equal to ninety
nine dollars and thirty will rounded
ninety-nine dollars and thirty seven
cents
ninety nine dollars and thirty seven
cents so now we've we can make a very
good comparison between the three
options this might have been confusing
before you know you have this guy coming
up to you and this guy is usually in the
form of some type of retirement plan or
insurance company where they say hey you
pay me this four years a B and C and
I'll pay you that here's B C and D and
you're like boy how do I compare if
that's really a good value well this is
how you compare you present value all of
the payments and you say well what is
that worth to me today and here we did
that and we said well actually choice
number one is the best deal and just
depending on how the mathematics work
out if I lower the discount rate if this
discount rate is lower it might have
changed the outcomes and maybe I'll
actually do that in the next video just
to show you how important the discount
rate is anyway I'm out of time and I'll
see you in the next video